rachel maddow cries corey lewandowski
laughs and the illegal immigration
fallout continues i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
so many feelings so many emotions so
much happening we'll go through all of
it in just one second first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over
Equipe so do you brush your teeth twice
a day do you do it for the proper amount
of time you have to lie to me okay look
I'm not your dentist you don't have to
lie you should just go get quit just
listen to me right now if you want to
have better mouth health well this is
what clip is for it's the new electric
toothbrush the packs just the right
amount of vibration into a slimmer
design in a fraction of the cost of
bulkier traditional electric brushes and
guiding pulses alert you when to switch
sides making brushing the right amount
effortless right amount of effortless
quip also comes to the mount that
suctions right to your mirror and on
sticks to use as a cover fry genic
travel anywhere it is a lot sleeker in
design than any of the other electric
toothbrushes that you are likely to get
it doesn't come with a charger because
the battery goes right in the toothbrush
and it works just great plus you can
also get new brush heads I'm a dentist
recommended schedule every three months
for just five dollars including free
shipping worldwide most super
toothbrushes don't get named one of Time
Magazine's best inventions of the year
equipped did for a reason it starts at
just 25 dollars if you go to get quip
comm slash Shapiro right now you'll get
your first refill pack absolutely free
with a quip electric toothbrush that is
your first refill pack free at get
equipped comm Shapiro
that's GE tqu IP comm slash apparel get
quip comm slash apparel I've been using
quip at home it is fantastic I love it
you should get it as well get quip comm
slash Shapiro alrighty so a lot to get
to today apparently the Trump
administration policy with regards to
separating children from parents which
is mandated by law if you're going to
arrest people criminally for crossing
the border
you cannot keep their kids in custody we
discuss this at length over the last
several days there's a court ruling from
2016 in which the court declared that
you cannot keep kids together with their
parents in fact the Obama administration
used to keep kids together with their
parents in detention proceedings and
then they were sued they were sued on
the basis that this was being used as a
deterrent to illegal immigration because
how dare you keep children in prisons
these are innocent kids why would you
keep them with their parents in prison
okay so the left sort of wants it both
ways they don't want you to be able to
keep the kids in prison with the parents
but they also don't want you to separate
the parents from the kids which leaves
only one solution of course which is
release the parents which is really what
they want out of this entire thing now
how do I know that this is what they
want from the entire spiel here well
because well the Democrats are out there
saying Nazi Nazi Nazi
not see about all of his policies about
all of his policy and let's be real I
did not see that coming well they're
saying all of this about Nazi policy
from the right the right is actually
attempting to solve this so Republicans
came forward yesterday Ted Cruz came
forward yesterday with a bill that would
fix all of this and say that children
can stay with their parents in detention
centers until all of the proceedings
have gone forward so what did Senate
Democratic leader Chuck Schumer do he
dismissed the legislative proposal he
said there are so many obstacles to
legislation and when the president can
do it with his own pen it makes no sense
legislation is not the way to go here
when it's so easy for the president to
sign it and then asked if that meant
Democrats would not support a bill
backed by Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell to keep immigrant families
together while seeking asylum on the US
border Schumer said they want to keep
the focus on Trump again quote
the president can change it with his pen
unacceptable editions have bogged down
every piece of legislation we've done so
in other words it's Nazi policy but if
the Republicans try to fix it there are
also Nazis which is pretty convenient
for the Democrats and as I said the
media coverage of this particular issue
has led Democrats to believe that the
issue doesn't need to be solved and
instead should be used as a club to
wield against everybody that you don't
like this is the plan by people like
Chuck Schumer on the left you can't have
it both ways either the policy is
straight from Japanese internment camps
in Nazi Germany in which case you should
be for anything that would alleviate the
policy or the policy is not that bad in
which case maybe we should argue over
the policy but the Democrats want to say
that the policy is awful it's evil it's
not yes kits Japanese immigrant and in
1942 it's all of those things but we're
not gonna work to solve it because it's
all on Trump okay all of which suggests
that a lot of the Democratic tears on
this are crocodile tears for political
gain no I'm not gonna say that everybody
who's upset over this policy is faking
it because I don't think that's right I
think a lot of people are upset over
this policy listen I don't think it's a
great policy I think it's a bad policy
but I also think that keeping kids
interned with parents is not a great
policy either there is no great policy
when it comes to illegal immigration in
the end as with war games the only
winning move is not to play right if you
don't want illegal immigrants separated
from their families or alternatively
kept with their families in detention
don't illegally immigrate you're going
to have to deter illegal immigration
that is the only solution because again
you can't say that you want kids to stay
with the families but you also want kids
released it's either one or the other
you can't have it both ways but it seems
that the left is more interested in
promulgating a particular
feeling about this policy than they are
about solving it it's just like gun
control every time there's a mass
shooting the left decides that it's
necessary to have these vast displays of
emotion these vast displays of empathy
and then they don't actually get
anything done because the policies they
call for have nothing to do with
actually stopping the crime at issue
well the same thing is happening here
the Republicans have proposed a
legislative fix the Democrats are
running away from that legislative fix
now they're urging President Trump to go
ahead and make an executive decision to
simply overrule the 9th Circuit Court of
Appeals decision in Flores and keep the
kids together with their parents how
long do you think it will take for
another lawsuit to be filed saying that
is unconstitutional for the kids to
remain together with their parents or
that is violation of the 1997 Flores
agreement with the federal government
it'll take exactly 5 seconds because we
just had those lawsuits again the Obama
administration kept children with
parents they were sued not to do that
they changed their policy not only did
they change their policy they had said
that they were keeping the kids together
with their parents as a deterrent and
the court said you're not allowed to do
that and now they're saying you can't
release the kids so you can't keep the
kids and you can't release the kids
because all the left really wants is
everyone released oh the all the emotion
that's coming out from this is is you
know on one on one level understandable
on another level irritating if you're
not gonna propose any solution so rachel
maddow last night on MSNBC she broke
down on air talking about migrant babies
being detained nobody is happy with the
idea of 12 month old babies I have a
two-year-old in the four year old no one
likes the idea of a two-year-old being
removed from their parents and crying
for mommy and daddy nobody likes this
which is why I've been saying
legislative fix from literally the first
day that this controversy broke onto the
scene but I will just point out that
Rachel Maddow has no such sympathy for
the hundreds of thousands of babies who
are killed in the womb every year she
has no such sympathy for kids who are
removed from their parents when parents
are arrested for domestic crimes Rachel
Maddow seems to me to be using emotion
as a sort of baton in order to try and
drive a particular narrative and that
narrative by the way is not creating
solutions again that narrative is
designed to let Democrats prevent
solutions that narrative is designed to
allow Democrats to emotionally
manipulate the American public without
working to fix the problem in the first
place here is Rachel Maddow / Michael
Mol's last night Trump administration
officials have been sending babe
and other young children Oh to at least
three three tender age shelters in South
Texas lawyers and medical providers just
I'm gonna have to hand this off okay the
tender age shelters by the way have
existed since 2010 under the Obama
administration I'll say this as somebody
who covers the news every day I'm not a
big fan of histrionics on air again I'm
sure that this is legit from from Rachel
Maddow okay I'm not gonna say that I
don't think that she feels this way I'm
sure she does feel this way but all of
us who are in the television business
all of us who are on camera on a regular
basis I would suggest that it is not a
good look for us to get so emotional
about issues that we can't discuss them
rationally
yeah but emotion emotional investment in
issues actually prevents rational
discussion of those issues but I think
the emotional investment is the entire
point at this point I think it's become
all about feelings and very little about
policy for example here's an NPR anchor
her last name is Kino Josa and and she
says that this is just like the Nazis
it's exactly like the Nazis on MSNBC
Elie Wiesel may he rest in peace what he
said to me was he said you know the
Nazis had it perfectly correct they
declared us an illegal people that's how
it began we were declared an illegal
people as Jews right and that follows
that they're not it's a very horrible
thing to make these comparisons but if
you think about the level of
dehumanization where we have arrived
where children are being taken there's
an arc there okay no there isn't you're
an idiot you're an idiot okay first I
would like to point out that everybody
in America seems to have read Harry
Potter and once heard of people called
the Nazis and every single issue must
fit into one of these two frameworks
into these two idiotic frameworks either
everything is a Harry Potter do-over or
everybody's a Nazi not everything you
dislike is Nazi policy gang read a
fricking book if you really believe that
Nazi policy was to have a process of law
whereby people who are illegally
attempting to enter Nazi Germany were
temporarily separated from their
children for the protection of the
children because we didn't want to hold
the children and incarcerated custody
and then they were reunited with those
children when people were deported if
you really think that was Nazi policy
it's because you're a as far as
the notion of dehumanization it is not
to who
the whole point here is that the Ninth
Circuit Court of Appeals most liberal
Court in America held that it is a
better policy to force parents and
children to be separated than to leave
children with parents in custody in the
first place again this was not Trump
coming up with you know what would be a
nefarious evil idea if we took those
kids away from those parents that is an
effectuation of law once you arrest
people the kids have to be removed by
force of law now it seems that today
Trump wants to change that by executive
order we'll see if he's even allowed to
get away with that it'll go straight to
court it'll probably be overturned
because in the end there is really an
agenda here but it drives me nuts when
people start invoking the Nazis when the
policy that is being discussed has
nothing to do with the Nazis Nazi is not
just shorthand for stuff I don't like
not a crime Nazi is like crying wolf now
there are actual Nazis yeah there are
actually people in the world to believe
the same thing the Nazis did the Iranian
regime believes the same thing the Nazis
did when it comes to extermination of
the Jews hey there are lots of people
across the world who believe in Nazi s
policy with regard to eugenic abortion
for example there are lots of people
across the world who believe not yes
fiscal policy but in order for you to
make a comparison you can't just say
look at that Trump he probably has a
swastika in his basement the only thing
separating Trump from Hitler is the
mustache you actually have to explain
why the policy that you say you oppose
is truly Nazi ask and to say that it's
all about dehumanization it's too vague
it's not about to humanization we're not
saying that these people should be taken
out and gassed we're not saying we
should be because you were taken out and
shot
I'm not happy with the treatment here
but to suggest that there is anything
remotely resembling Nazi policy
happening here is insulting to Americans
it's insulting to the Trump
administration it's insulting to the
people who carry it out it really is
insulting to the to the ICE agents I'd
like to point out because we've been
brought up on the notion you don't get
to follow a bad order you don't get to
follow an evil order that if somebody
tells you to go out in public and shoot
some innocent bystander that you have to
refuse that order right or if said the
Nuremberg defense I was only following
orders doesn't apply morally are we
really now suggesting that ice agents
are the equivalent of Nazis the ice
agents who are carrying out these orders
to separate the kids as per policy
promulgated by the 9th Circuit Court of
Appeals and those people are exactly the
same as the brown shirts or the
Auschwitz guards is that really what we
are saying here now and it's it's
constant right Soledad O'Brien's we did
the same thing out Soledad O'Brien
tweeted out well I guess
we put to rest the question Nazi Germany
could it happen here in America I'll
discuss in a second why this is so
idiotic but first I want to say thanks
to our sponsors over at Skillshare so
right now there's a lot of movement in
the job market people move job to job
you're not gonna be at the same job that
you are now probably in ten years people
move every five years or so in their
jobs as opposed to you back in your
grandpa's day when they stayed at GM for
50 years and earned the gold watch that
means you have to constantly be updating
a resume you have to constantly be
adding to your skill set and that is
what skill share is for it's an online
learning platform with over 20,000
classes in business design technology
and more you can take classes in social
media marketing illustration data
science mobile photography I've taken
one in watercolours take another one in
social media marketing all the classes
are taught by experts they're about 45
minutes long and they really are
excellent okay you will have a level of
expertise you didn't think you would
have after you take a Skillshare class
and right now if you join Skillshare you
get two months for just 99 cents the
skill share is offering ben shapiro show
listeners two months of unlimited access
to 20,000 classes for just 99 cents if
he wasn't really try no you like
learning and that's what skills share
does better than pretty much anyone else
sign up go to skill shared comm Shapiro
that skill share calm / prepare to start
your two months for 99 cents right now
skills shared comm slash Shapiro one
more time skill shared calm / Pierrot
use that / appear so they know he's
telling you okay so Soledad O'Brien
tweets out but this is just like Nazi
Germany she tweets out that Nazi Germany
could happen here now I've always
believed that the rise of fascism in
Germany is inexplicable phenomenon
people tend to treat it as though the
entire country just went crazy all of a
sudden in the entire country just
suddenly decided that they were going to
start exterminating Jews and going to
war with all the surrounding countries
and when you actually spend a fair bit
of time studying the rise of Nazi
Germany as I have then what you will see
is that there was an organic process by
which the Nazis ended up taking over
Germany and actually the detainer should
pre-existed the Nazis that the existence
of a dictatorial power in the center of
German government pre-existed the Nazis
began about 1930 culminated in 1932 it
was it was essentially a non elected
government or at least if it was elected
it was it was running not along the
basis of a legislature for a long time
in Germany before the Nazis even took
power I've always believed that human
beings can slide into evil a lot more
easily than we like to think that we
could but what Soledad O'Brien is saying
which is that we are now like Nazi
Germany or becoming like Nazi Germany
when we set
right kids from parents at the border
okay what's your alternative what sir
I'm fine with not separating kids from
parents at the border so there's Ted
Cruz hos Donald Trump but the Democrats
don't want any sort of policy that will
fix this which demonstrates full-scale
that all of this is really just
emotional manipulation by the left if
you're not gonna solve the problem if
you're not gonna propose any solution
other than yelling at Trump and then
suggesting that he release everybody on
mass we're not criminally prosecuted
legal immigration then you're not
contributing to a solution to the
problem you're just using this as a
political club to wield and and you can
see the extent to which the media have
gone overboard so for example the New
Yorker decided that they were going to
target a particular ice agent so they
showed a picture of an ice agent and
they said this man has a has a Nazi
tattoo all right so the New Yorker did
was put out a picture of a Marine
veteran accusing him of having a Nazi
tattoo because he works for ice hay and
the picture shows a guy with a series of
tattoos on his arm like a lot of guys
who are our military or ex-military well
now it turns out that all of that is
nonsense okay the guy who she took a
picture of this particular this
particular reporter she tweeted about a
guy named Justin Gartner and Gartner is
a combat combat wounded veteran a nice
forensic analyst and she said they had a
Nazi Iron Cross inked on his elbow but
it turns out that it's a maltese crossed
a symbol associated with fire fighters
the tattoo according Gartner is actually
a titan-2 symbol for his platoon when he
served in Afghanistan according to ice
the writing on his right arm is the
Spartan Creed which is about protecting
family and children anyone attempting to
advance their personal political
opinions by baselessly slandering an
American Hero should be issuing public
apologies to mr. ghertner and the
refractions this includes Levin and The
New Yorker
Colonel lost both his legs and suffered
other permanent injuries when an AED
exploded during his deployment to
Helmand province Afghanistan he served
as a fireteam leader and lead sweeper
for IEDs but he works for ice that means
he's evil that means that he's akin to
Nazis well in just a second I want to
talk about how the Trump administration
is responding to all of this plus some
more of the fallout from the left so
it's not just members of the government
members of the press who are doing this
it's also virtually signaling on the
part of people in Hollywood so now
there's been a lot of talk in Hollywood
about various members of Fox Television
Studios disassociating from Fox
generally because they don't like Fox
News's coverage so Steve Levitan who
the co-creator of Modern Family he says
Fox studio has been a wonderful home for
most of my career so many amazing people
that who share the concerns about Fox
News but aren't in the position to speak
out I have no problem with facts based
fact-based conservatism such as The Wall
Street Journal but Fox News is 23 hour a
day support of the NRA conspiracy
theories and Trump lies get harder to
swallow every day as I Drive on to that
lot to make a show about inclusion I
look forward to seeing Modern Family
through to the end and then sailor knows
he'll setting up shop elsewhere well
first of all important to note 21st
Century Fox is made up of several key
assets Fox Television Studios has
nothing to do with Fox News okay they
are completely separate branches of Fox
and in fact after Fox is sold there's a
good likelihood that Fox News doesn't
even end up going along with the rest of
Fox being sold to Disney so as possible
ends I was a completely separate company
but all of this virtue signaling makes
perfect sense Steve Levitan contract is
up in 2019 right it's coming up for
renewal next year anyway Seth MacFarlane
also tweeted that he was embarrassed to
work for Fox not embarrass to clear
those checks by the way he added quote
in other words don't think critically
don't consult multiple news sources and
in general don't use your brain just
blindly obey Fox News this is fringe
bleep and it's business like this that
makes me embarrassed to work for this
company and there's Paul Feig who made
lady Ghostbusters and tweeted I've made
two films for 20th Century Fox and love
the people in the movie and TV divisions
but I too cannot condone the support
their news division promotes sort of the
immoral and abusive policies and actions
taken by this current administration
toward immigrant children Ellison it's a
free country you can do whatever you
want you don't want to work with Fox by
all means don't work on Fox but if you
truly believe that you're going to
impact the coverage of Fox News by
leaving a Fox television studio it's one
of the things that toxify politics that
we can't have free and open discussion
about politics without people
threatening to boycott one another is
not the world's best element it's not
the world's best thing and we're seeing
that increasingly this this was most
obvious last night so Christian Nielsen
who is the who is the secretary for
homeland security she was eating dinner
at a Mexican restaurant and activists
decided that would be worthwhile to get
her thrown out of the restaurant the
David they would protest and chance
until they ruined her dinner
[Music]
separation deportation thousand children
separated from their parents tens of
thousands of people who come here
seeking asylum in the United States we
provide you to a family separation okay
so great to mess up everybody's dinner
bit over the policy I'll listen I
understand the passion I understand you
don't like the policy but this sort of
this sort of young fascist mentality
that you're gonna go into restaurants
and ruin people's lives because you have
disagreements over policy if you don't
like the policy vote for people who are
gonna change the policy if you don't
like the policy go file a lawsuit if you
don't like the policy harassing other
Americans and trying to destroy their
their personal time seems to me
ridiculous and I understand that that
you think that she's complicit in a bad
policy but how would the left have
treated it if people on the right had
gone in ruined Obama administration's
official officials dinner over Obamacare
would that be decent
would that make for a better America of
course not of course and then Anna
Navarro who's just completely lost her
mind
she tweeted out are there no Norwegian
restaurants in Washington DC because the
great crime here is that Christian
Nielsen was eating Mexican food
Wow just you know how dare she Mexican
food well also having a particular
policy that prevents illegal immigration
how dare she
how dare she well what you can see is
this drives a reactionary response and
so what we've got now is reactionary
policy and and propaganda and rhetoric
on all sides of the aisle none of it is
particularly good I understand president
Trump responding with ire so while the
media coverage which as I have said for
the last week I think is completely
uncalled for I think it is not only
undignified I think it is inaccurate and
it is promulgating policies that are not
actually good for the country it's
preventing the creation of policy that
will actually fix all of this but I'm
not sure the media care about all that
own thing Hollywood cares about any of
this stuff with all of that said with
all that said the reaction by some
people on the right has been reactionary
in the extreme as well so you've got the
left reacting to what is a controversial
policy by suggesting that this is now
Nazi Germany and then you have the right
responding to that with some of the
frederik that I've seen on the right in
quite a while I'll get to that in just
second first I wanna say thanks to our
sponsor is over at ring so our sponsors
over at ring they're the video doorbell
company that allows you to see and speak
to anyone when they come to your door
well now they've actually sent us
footage of ring busting crooks in the
act this one is is pretty creepy so what
you're going to hear is it's nighttime a
woman catches a strange man standing at
her door and she speaks to him using the
ring video doorbell - good thing she had
it because if she had not then this
imagine if she'd actually opened the
door to see that this was hey sorry
we're in the middle of dinner can I help
you yes how are you good how are you
good seen you in a while I don't know
who you are I'm Justin I met you long
time ago for both gods
so then thank you thank you Justin okay
it's a good thing that you had ring
video doorbell there otherwise we
wouldn't have our next guest for the
Sunday special we're gonna have to have
Justin on for the Sunday special and
that would be a weird conversation but
the obviously it's a good thing that
ring exists because a lot can happen at
your front door a lot of people knock on
the door to see if you're home before
they rob the place and you can be
anywhere in the country and you can you
can pick up the the ring video doorbell
anywhere in the country even if you're
not at home that's the wonderful thing
about a plus they have rings plug like
ham spot like ham they let you build a
ring of security around your entire
property stop crime before it happens
make your neighborhood safer with ring
save up to one hundred and fifty bucks
off a ring of security kit at ring comm
/ Ben that's ring calm / Ben $150 off
when you go to ring calm / Ben go check
it out we at the Shapiro household use
ring calm it is fantastic we use the
ring
we also are getting the ring of security
ket it is it's terrific I mean I use it
all the time when I'm out of town
somebody rings the doorbell I wanna know
who it is
ring calm makes that happens hey 150
bucks off and you go to ring calm / Ben
okay so the Trump administration has
responded to all of the media
malfeasance here with I think a
justifiable amount of outrage so
president Trump has defended Christian
Nielsen his Secretary of Homeland
Security he he said that she's done a
fabulous job at the presser he tweeted
out homeland security secretary Nielsen
did a fabulous job yesterday at the
press conference explaining security at
the burner and for our country about the
same time recommending changes to
obsolete and nasty laws which forced
family separation we weren't hurt and
security in America okay well that's
fine I don't see a huge problem with any
of that I think that that's probably
exactly right and I also think that
President Trump would like to solve this
right president Trump is interested in
doing something about this the problem
of course is that the minute that he
issues an executive order saying that
kids can stay with their families the
left Susan says the kids can't be held
in jail so we'll see how well that works
well it Trump's the problem is that the
Trump administration has handled this
about as badly as you can handle the
rollout of anything it's the worst
rollout for a major policy initiative
for the Trump administration since the
travel ban happened at the very
beginning of the administration when
they were going out there suggesting
that they were going to prevent veterans
who are serving abroad and were of
Muslim descent from and re-entering the
country and such you know this is a very
very bad policy rollout I mean just
again I don't think the policy is is
inexcusable I don't think it's
unjustifiable on a legal level I think
it should be changed but do I think that
the rollout has been good no the rollout
has just been absolute garbage and it's
a mistake because what's happened is
that the left has gone so polarized that
the right has responded by also going
polarized plus you're gonna need some
better spokespeople I think the
Christian Nielsen is just fine but
here's Trump's ice director who's he
asked whether the policy was humane and
this did not go well for him on CNN is
this new zero-tolerance policy that the
president has supported that the
Attorney General announced is it humane
I think I I think it's the law as a long
a be the law it's the policy but is it
humane I think it's the law and I'm a
law enforcement must follow along okay
that is not a good answer what he should
say is my personal opinion is that this
law should be changed to make it better
but that is not the responsibility of
the executive branch if you're asking me
what's more humane keeping kids with
their parents in prison or not keeping
their kids with the parents in prison
well then I'm not sure of the answer to
that but I also think that it is
inhumane released vast bevies of illegal
immigrants into the interior of the
country without any capacity to get them
at catch and release is not a decent
policy but it's not even that sort of
media attention that is that is really
the worst the worst is Corey Lewandowski
so Corey Lewandowski is just garbage
okay Corey Lewandowski was campaign
manager for a certain period of time
during the Trump campaign he was garbage
then his garbage
now he's really bad at his job he's on
Fox News last night and he was
confronted by an illegal immigrant
advocate in an advocate for illegal
immigration and in this this advocate
for legal immigration talks about a
really terrible case of a of a kid with
Down syndrome separated from the kids
parents who crossed the border illegally
and Corey Lewandowski response to this
with all the compassion of a potato so
here he is I read today about a ten year
old girl with Down syndrome who was
taken from her mother and put in a cage
I read about a a they just they won't
want to a ten year old with Down
syndrome with anything but the bottom
that is very youth okay that is nuts
okay forget about the reaction of the
guy which is which is made for TV but
Corey Lewandowski womp womp to a story
of a ten year old with Down syndrome
being removed from her parents no and
then you here's a problem you can do
this policy and still look compassionate
you can do this policy and still say I
want to change the state of the law
because we have to both enforce our
borders and we have to ensure that kids
are taken care of these are not mutually
exclusive
but Corey Lewandowski is such an idiot
that he goes on TV and makes it sound
like he doesn't care what happens to
Down's syndrome children who are ten
years old and removed from their parents
it wasn't anybody with any iota of
sympathy feels terrible for these kids
you remember when you were left at
summer camp imagine that except that you
were forcibly removed to summer camp and
your parents didn't know where you were
going okay the policy itself is deeply
flawed but again this is not on the
Trump administration this is on the 9th
Circuit Court of Appeals and the fact
that this was never solved at the
legislative level for the last 20 odd
years but to just go out there and say
womp womp when you're talking about some
of these heartbreaking stories idiotic
in the extreme foolish in the extreme
because Corey Lewandowski is an idiot
Corey lewandowski's a fool there's talk
about him coming back his chief of staff
or bringing him back into the Trump
administration Trump would be foolish to
do that really foolish to do that to
bring Corey Lewandowski the man the man
has the honest-to-god the man has the IQ
of a chilled vegetable not even like a
room tempura
that's been in the fridge for too long
and it started to mold it's so bad for
Trump's policy it's bad for the
president to have representatives like
Corey Lewandowski going womp womp when
people are talking about the suffering
of children
would be the equivalent of after
Parkland somebody goes on TV and they're
talking about the horrors that happened
to parkland and instead of people saying
yes that was indeed horrifying and
terrible we need to find a way to stop
that one of the ways to stop that is not
gun control but better school security
would be like Corey Lewandowski going on
TV and somebody's talking about somebody
shot to death in a school when Corey
Lewandowski goes womp womp because any
and this is this kind of this sort
of political polarization in sort of
political conflicts where rhetoric on
both sides matters much more than
workable policy it really makes me angry
it's really frustrating it's really
stupid because there is a workable
policy solution to all of this Ted Cruz
proposed it yesterday
now Ted Cruz's bill right which is
supposed to be brought up I guess today
in the House of Representatives right
with them with the help of speaker Ryan
the house is gonna vote on a bill that
unites illegal immigrant families at the
border and Democrats are expected to
vote against the bill they're getting a
clean standalone bill to formally
prevent child separation and they're
going to vote no on mass and says guy
Benson demonstrating once again the bad
faith the Democrats have on this entire
issue now Republicans have a win if they
will compassionate but that means you
can't send out people who are cretins to
represent you on television
you can't send out Corey Lewandowski the
last time an object passed through his
head was never I mean and I'm talking
I'm including his brain I mean it like
there's nothing in there
there's an old there's an old headline
about Dizzy Dean Dizzy Dean was a famous
pitcher for the st. Louis Cardinals back
in the 1940s and a huge famous for being
kind of a nut case and he was he was
trying to steal second base and the
catcher tried to throw him out and hit
him in the head with the ball and and
the headlines the next day read dizzy
Dean's head x-rayed nothing revealed and
that is pretty much corey lewandowski
x-ray that dude's head and it looks like
a balloon sending him out as
representative for the administration is
so deeply unhelpful but it didn't stop
there then you have a trump advisor who
goes on CNN and he calls illegal
immigrants invaders this is just it is
not useful guys and policy that Trump is
purporting to push here is not a bad
policy in terms of strict enforcement of
the border I like strict enforcement of
law it lets us know whether it
you can't tell whether a law is bad or
good until it's fully enforced and Trump
wants to change the law now sending out
people to call illegal immigrants
invaders while the left is showing
pictures of children is not exactly
bright Bader's
they are immigrants okay Steve okay you
know this is obviously good for America
this sort of political conversation
where guy says invaders and then someone
screams for five minutes just at the top
of her lungs yes the very very good
stuff CNN well played excellent coverage
you can't have articulate people on from
both sides to actually you know act as
experts on what applies here instead you
have people one guy come on to out
invaders so that the base gets all riled
up and they're really exciting so we're
stopping the invasion it's like Starship
Troopers okay but and then you have
people on the other side who are who are
going around shouting they call them
invaders it's a bunch of children their
children and crying onto it yes this is
all good I can't imagine why the
politics in America so degraded maybe
it's because we're busy calling each
other Nazis invading each other's
dinners and then yelling at each other
about invasions and and whomp-whomp and
all the rest of it the level of
discourse in this country is become so
intensely stupid I'm not sure they can
never be put back together again okay a
few more notes on that plus Peter struck
some and some notes that that affect him
the FBI agents who said he would stop
Trump we'll talk about that in just a
second first we're gonna have to go over
to Daily wire comment subscribe for
$9.99 a month you can subscribe to daily
wire.com and get the rest of this show
live get the rest of Andrew Klavan show
live Michael moles is show live also it
means you get to be part of the mailbag
which will be doing on Friday and if you
subscribe then yesterday could have
asked me questions in the conversation
it was the angriest episode of the
conversation ever and you could have
asked us questions on it if you've been
a subscriber but if you didn't subscribe
that's your own fault if you get the
annual subscription ninety nine dollars
a year it is cheaper than the monthly
Plus you got this invisible leftist
tears
hot or cold tumblr right it's so good
that I activated the invisibility switch
it is just that incredible and you get
that for free when you get the annual
subscription also you should go over to
our YouTube you should go over to our
iTunes and you should check it out
because we have Sunday specials now our
Sunday specials involve long-form
interviews with some of the most
interesting thinkers in America this
week we interviewed Jason Whitlock
formerly of ESPN formerly Kansas City
Star sports columnist we talked about
everything from the black community's
politics to the to the effect of sports
on our general culture here's a little
bit of what it looked like hi I'm Jason
Whitlock of Fox Sports one tune in this
Sunday to the bins
Piro Sunday special I'll be talking
about my faith in God
the NFL National Anthem controversy
Donald Trump and a bunch of other stuff
my entire background it's a great show
don't miss it okay so that'll be awesome
check that out on Sunday Jason's a great
interview and it was really a lot of fun
and I think there's some depth to it as
well so check that out subscribe in
iTunes subscribe at YouTube please leave
this review it always helps cure the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so final note on all the hysteria
surrounding in this illegal immigration
controversy this all could be solved so
easily if people pulled their heads out
of their colons and stopped calling each
other Nazis but that's not going to
happen instead we're gonna listen to
people like Peter Fonda right who hasn't
been relevant in several decades who's
tweeting out quote sounds great
we don't have to take the agents kids we
only need to surround their schools and
scare the bleep out of them and worry
the eff out of the agents from CBE
eyes--and regular Border Patrol agents
we need to scare the eff out of them
this all caps now need to make their
children worried now we should hack the
system get the addresses of the ice age
and CPB agents and surround their homes
in protest we should find out what
schools their children go to and
surround the schools and protest these
agents are doing this because they want
to do it they like doing this F we want
to stop this epic monster really want to
stop this giant a-hole 90 million people
in the streets on the same weekend these
Republican a-holes are all in on it
the chief a-hole was happy we are all
very upset we have to get even more
angry with these Republicans yeah that's
gonna solve it getting more angry I'm
sure more anger will solve this Andrew
Klavan he says some wise things and one
of the wise things that Andrew Clavin
says is that anger is the devil's
cocaine well clearly everybody is high
right now hey somebody got a hold of the
crack supply and they have mainstreamed
it into the water
they've just diluted the water with
crack because the anger is palpable and
none of it is directed toward actually
solving things if you think that
targeting Border Patrol agents as though
they're Nazis is going to solve this
problem you have another thing company
coming you want you want to alienate the
other side more you want the other side
to become more reactionary then this is
the area where I say that you know when
Soledad O'Brien says we could become
like Nazi Germany then she points at the
border policy
I say that's idiotic but I'll tell you
one of the things that did lead to the
rise of the Nazis was reactionary
politics because by the time the Nazis
were elected in 1933 and they were
elected in 1933 by the time they were
elected and Hitler became Chancellor of
Germany the only two rising forces in
the country were the Communists and the
Nazis the Social Democrats were sort of
the center party they were sort of
holding the country together they were
the the governing party for most of the
vitamin Republic they had failed to
clamp down on the violence between the
Communists and the Nazis and what that
had led to was this reactionary politics
where the Communists were reacting
against the Nazis the Nazis were
reacting against the Communists and
people felt they had a binary choice
between the Nazis and the Communists in
Germany and most people chose the
Communists
chose the Nazis or at least a plurality
chose the Nazis well the more we a lien
ate each other the more we treat each
other not as brothers but as enemies the
more we don't have decent conversations
and instead leap to call each other the
worst scourge 'as of the earth the more
obvious it's going to become that we
can't live together and then you're
going to get more reactionary
politicians on both sides it's gonna
turn into every election is going to
turn into corey lewandowski shouting
womp womp and peter fonda shouting that
cpp agents should be should have their
houses surrounded by illegal immigrants
activists if you want the country to
fray at the edges this is how you do it
this is lack of a common culture it's
lack of a civil culture it's lack of a
belief that we are united as Americans
in any serious way now how much of the
country really is into this I don't
think it's as large a percentage as
everybody else does but it doesn't have
to be a large percentage in order to
disorder to destroy our politics the
most extreme can pull everybody else
along I've talked on the show before
about the phenomenon renormalization
renormalization is the idea that people
who exist on the fringes of politics can
pull other people along with them the
example that I've used in in you know
kind of everyday life is an example
given by a Nicholas and a scene Talib
the author of Black Swan who and and in
the book skin in the game he talks about
how it is that you can have an entire
party that ends up providing vegetarian
food as opposed to me simply because one
person is vegetarian the way that it
starts is that you have one family of
say four people and you have a child in
that family who's vegetarian and mom
decides that she doesn't actually want
to cook two separate meals for kid and
the rest of the family say it's just too
much hassle so everybody's gonna eat
vegetarian tonight and then that part
that that family decides to go to a
party right and they go to this this
party and they say listen what we're
doing vegetarian because we're trying to
keep up with with our daughter here Lisa
Simpson we're trying to be vegetarian
just like Lisa and now we're going to go
to a party and they're only four
families coming and if a host of the
party has a choice they can either cook
two meals one vegetarian one
non-vegetarian or they can cook one meal
all vegetarian and this is how you get
20 people who are all eating vegetarian
because one person needs vegetarian you
can see the same thing happening with
regard to our politics you see somebody
who's extreme say to the rest of the
crowd listen I'm not gonna go along with
your agenda I'm gonna keep shouting Nazi
Nazi Nazi over and over and over unless
you placate me and a bunch of people who
are standing there with them go oh what
the hell you know I sort of agree with
the basic political just that they're
that they are speaking of and I don't
really want to call them out for the
Nazi line
I agree with them more than I disagree
with them so I guess that I'll just kind
of go silence on the Nazi stuff this is
how you get extreme rhetoric on both
sides right this is how you got one guy
who says womp womp and then a huge
Twitter following that says yeah he's
right to say womp womp and the the the
the polarization of the politics is not
good for the country and again it
prevents good policy from getting done
here's the best policy
strict border enforcement strict border
control kids stay with the parents until
they are deported more funding advice
more funding of the immigration courts
more funding of the deportation the
deportation of holding centers write
more funding of all of this hey this is
an actual legitimate function of
government okay
unlike a lot of the social safety net
that's been created over the last
hundred and fifty years in this country
there is no reason why we should not be
funding actual border enforcement in
proper way and then we cannot do so
humanely we should be doing so humanely
but all that's being obfuscated by the
the crying histrionics on television it
makes me just nuts it's just it's just
gross okay so meanwhile there's been a
lot of talk over the last couple of
weeks about the Department of Justice
inspector general report in which FBI
agent Peter struck you remember him he
was leading the Hillary investigation
and the Russian investigation and he was
also stripping a fellow FBI agent it
turns out well he was texting her in the
middle of the election cycle that he was
going to stop president rumble yesterday
Peter struck was actually thrown out of
the FBI building he was escorted from
the FBI building according to media I
FBI agent Peter struck who is revealed
to have sent texts showing animosity
toward president Trump's campaign
according to a recent investigator
general report was removed Friday from
the FBI building it was reported by
multiple outlets on Tuesday afternoon
CNN reporter Laura Jarrett's we did the
news Tuesday noting that struck had not
been fired but has been kept in human
resources following his dismissal from
Robert Muller's investigative team I'm
kind of shocked of course that Peter
struck has not been fired in a statement
tweeted by CBS's Paula Reid Struck's
lawyer eight-time Goldman said his
client has steadfastly played by the
rules and respected the process but
continues to be the target of unfounded
personal attacks political games and
inappropriate information leaks all of
that is false the Inspector General said
that this sort of bias was some of the
worst that he had ever seen at the FBI
so it's about time for Peter struck to
lose his job it's long past time for
Peter struck to use his lose his job of
course now in actual good news today
nikki Haley
along with Mike Pompeo the Secretary of
State they've announced that the United
States is going to withdraw funding from
the UN Human Rights count
this is a good thing because the Human
Rights Council is filled with some of
the world's worst human rights violators
there's no reason we should be funding
that agency the Bush administration also
by the way pulled out of the Human
Rights Council it was only the Obama
administration because they wanted to
kowtow to the world's worst countries
that decided to to refund the HRC well
nikki Haley who is indeed my spirit
animal at the UN she announced the
United States is pulling out of the HRC
regrettably it is now clear that our
call for reform was not heeded human
rights abusers continue to serve on and
be elected to the council the world's
most inhumane regimes continue to escape
scrutiny and the council continues to
politicizing and scapegoating of
countries with positive human rights
records in an attempt to distract from
the abusers in their ranks therefore as
we said we would do a year ago if we did
not see any progress the United States
is officially withdrawing from the UN
Human Rights Council well this is
excellent news literally half of all UN
resolutions at the Human Rights Council
criticizing a country have not been
directed at North Korea or Iran or Saudi
Arabia or Egypt or China or Venezuela or
Cuba virtually half of them have been
directed against Israel okay according
to UN watch they're 135 critical
resolutions from 2006 to 2016 68 of them
50% were directed at Israel the whole
thing has just become a sham and a
debacle there's no reason the United
States should be spending taxpayer
dollars funding a garbage institution
like the UN as a whole let alone the UN
Human Rights Council so that is good
news in other sort of predictable news
Starbucks has now had to cut stores so
this is hilarious and Starbucks which
has been focused I don't know where the
homeless are gonna go now I'm not sure
where people are gonna pee now we've
heard the only place that people are
allowed to pee and hang out is Starbucks
but apparently the the head of Starbucks
chief executive officer Kevin Johnson
has given news to investors and he said
that the company's recent not acceptable
performance is going to cause it to
streamline to improve innovation agility
and re accelerate growth this means that
the company revealed a disappointing 1%
sales increase globally in the current
quarter about a third of the expected 3
percent growth projected by analysts
Bloomberg explained that some of the
streamlining Johnson referred to will
come in the form of shutting down about
150 company operated stores intensely
penetrated US markets next fiscal year
which leaves a serious question where
are people going to poop we have heard
that the only place people can poop is
it a Starbucks you know you have to buy
coffee there anymore you just go there
you hang out you poop in their bathrooms
well with those bathrooms closed to the
general public will the streets be piled
high with the feces of dispossessed
Americans how exactly our Americans
gonna get their garbage coffee and how
exactly are they going to pee anymore
will America become urine town
we don't know the answers to these vital
and crucial questions this is what
happens when you run your company like a
social justice warrior idiot center as
opposed to running it like an actual
coffee company so Starbucks is a broad
growth has been quite strong but in the
United States it's having some serious
problems with about fourteen thousand
stores domestically according to
Bloomberg Starbucks is now pumping the
brakes unlicensed and company operated
locations with a renewed focus on rural
and suburban areas not over caffeinated
or urban neighborhoods where locals
already joke the next Starbucks will
open inside an existing store which is
basically right every Starbucks is
located across the street from another
Starbucks because they figure you're too
lazy to walk across the street well
they'd saturated the markets but they've
also alienated a lot of customers with a
lot of the nonsense they've been
pursuing for the last little while and I
can't say I am completely displeased
with Starbucks as poor performance given
their politics over the last couple of
years okay time for some things by the
way it doesn't mean you should we should
boycott Starbucks I don't think should
boycott companies almost their policies
affect you okay time for some things I
like and then some things that I hate so
things I like today so my wife got into
this show on Amazon sneaky pete which is
a it's it's all about a con artist
basically um it gets out to more intense
as the first season goes on it's it's
kind of cleverly written I don't think
it's it's a world-shaking show but it's
enjoyable it's an it's an enjoyable kind
of fun romp and I'm a sucker for movies
and shows about con artists so the this
is the show's Thank You Pete here's is
sneaky
Pete it is from Amazon right here's what
it looks like hi grandma
grandpa it's me Pete
[Music]
we make money by knowing who we can
trust and here we can't trust you're a
clone I'm a confidence man I make people
feel confident they give me their money
you stole from me you can't have that
then you're gonna talk your way out of
this when you talk to a into the school
I'm a very reasonable man I'm trying to
help you okay so Bryan Cranston is the
best part of the show because Bryan
Cranston is the best part of every show
he's a producer on the show and he plays
this this gangster mob villain and it's
it's a fun show it's definitely worth
the watch and and it's enjoyable okay
time for a quick thing that I hate so
every movie it is now it is now
indicated by Hollywood that every single
movie that is made must have some sort
of LGBTQ reference it doesn't matter if
it's involved in the plot at all it
doesn't matter if it has anything to it
the characters we have to throw in some
oblique reference to somebody being gay
a lesbian it's very very important this
happened and then right before release
we'll cut all those references right
this is what Hollywood does so they did
it in black panther there's apparently a
lesbian reference that happened in the
middle of the film and then it was just
sort of cut because they realized oh
wait a second a bunch of 10 year olds
are gonna watch this film and maybe we
don't want ten year olds thinking about
lesbianism in the middle of a film about
black panther
maybe that's silly maybe we shouldn't
actually do that because that's really
political well they're now doing the
same thing with Jurassic world fallen
kingdoms so apparently there was a scene
where is a star named Daniella Panetta
on and a line of dialogue was cut from
the film that would have revealed that
her character Zia Rodriguez was a
lesbian she says I understood why they
cut it for the sake of time it's me and
Chris Pratt and we're in a military
vehicle with all these mercenaries I
looked at Chris and I'm like yeah square
jaw good bone structure tall muscles
I don't date men but if I did it would
be you it would gross me out but I would
do it okay now question why was that in
the film in the first place was deeply
important to know that this character
who probably will be eaten by a dinosaur
as a lesbian is that really really
important why is that something that we
definitely needed to know did we need to
know Jeff Goldblum's
sexuality he's just a weirdo right we
didn't know Jeff Goldblum sexuality in
the original Jurassic Park this whole
idea that we have to insert social
justice messaging into filmed in the
most obvious and clunky possible way is
really stupid now there are plenty of
shows there plenty of movies where a
character's homosexuality is integral to
the plot so for example a couple of days
ago I recommend a show called Animal
Kingdom one of the sons is gay there's
actually somewhat integral to the plot
it actually goes to character but just
randomly suggesting that somebody is gay
or lesbian and that this somehow
magically changes the entire fabric of
the movie is really stupid
right it's it's it's something that
people feel something that people do
something that P is it's an orientation
but it's also an activity but
nothing to do with hunting dinosaurs
like what exactly makes it have anything
to do with hunting 9 is I don't know I
don't know but this is but then glad is
gonna complain about it right so this is
my favorite part so virtually every film
virtually every TV show is pre-screened
for glad the Gay and Lesbian Alliance
Against Defamation so glad can vet it
first which is a little bit Orwellian
right we don't we don't have that among
conservatives right we don't get to
actually pre-screen all the movies to
say hey that's really insulting the
christians if we did that half the
movies that exist would not actually be
able to come out in their current form
but the the glad glad does these long
reports about exactly what percentage of
studio films include LGBTQ characters so
they say that twelve point eight percent
of studio films from last year included
LGBTQ characters the lowest percentage
since the organization began keeping
tabs in 2012 the organization's report
notes that this year films such as gay
teen romance love Simon and Deadpool -
which featured a lesbian x-men couple
have raised the bar for representation
but other projects that have drawn upon
source material featuring LGBTQ
characters opted not to depict them on
screen in that way Tessa Thompson noted
that her thor ragnarok character
Valkyrie is bisexual in the comics and
though that isn't addressed in the film
the actress was faithful to that and her
depiction it very important that we make
sure that there are bisexual characters
in all of our comic book movies deeply
deeply important you know you wouldn't
want to alienate gays and lesbians who
wouldn't otherwise watch a comic book
movie if there's not a gay fake
fictional character living in an off
world scenario but just like to point
one thing out if 12.8% of studio films
included LGBTQ characters which
presumably means that you know a major
percentage of these films like about 2%
of the American population is actually
LGBTQ like openly identifies as LGBTQ
not 12.8% now you might say well there
are lots of characters in these films
that's true but if only about 2% of the
American population identifies as openly
LGBTQ that means that very few people
are actually associating in many places
in the country with people who are LGBTQ
so if you're just representing stories
then not all of the stories are going to
include gay characters right not
everybody has a gay friend or a gay
person who is integral to the plot of
their character integral to the plot of
their life and even if they are gay what
does that have to do with most movies
most movies don't reveal the sexuality
of random characters so it's it's all
it's all very weird it's all very
useless but again it is it is designed
to appease a particular social justice
crowd in film you want
characters in film go for it so long as
it's actually relevant to the plot in
the character but the suggestion that
every character who every character has
to have their sexual orientation
revealed because even in the most
oblique way it's relevant to character
is really stupid there are a lot of gay
people a lot of straight people who
don't identify their their sexual
orientation as the key components of
their life what makes them a good or bad
person or relevant to any particular
story okay we'll be back here tomorrow
with all the latest news I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wha
era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
Ford publishing production copyright
Ford publishing 2018